so today we're talking about what went
wrong with halo infinite's 2020 campaign
demo we're also going to talk about the
multiplayer getting more playlists
finally
the head of halo developer 343
industries bonnie ross has shed some new
light on the poorly received july 2020
halo infinite campaign demo explaining
what went wrong and why raw said that
because developers were mostly working
from home at the time due to the
pandemic not everyone working on the
game saw the same picture quality for
the demo different team members were
working on different monitors with
different color settings and such so the
result became a huge wake-up call for
them bonnie even acknowledges that some
people working on the game raised
concerns but ultimately microsoft moved
ahead and this was a misstep later in
the interview ross spoke about why halo
infinite's develop time has been so long
she said part of it came down to
building a new engine slip space and
pushing the series into new directions
with free to play multiplayer and a
quote more expansive world for the
campaign she said quote it's kind of
like trying to fly a plane while you're
still building the plane and i think
that that just caused a lot of pain for
people things just took way longer than
they should to get the content into the
game and make sure the content is
polished but at least it wasn't all bad
they learned so much more about remote
development and we got craig and who
doesn't love craig for the full
interview head on over to our sister
site cena
and sticking with the halo campaign news
the game is doing very well critically
proving that the year-long delay was
well worth it over here at gamespot
jordan gave halo infinite a 9 out of 10.
and if you want to know why make sure to
watch the review after this video
and over on the multiplayer side of
things 343 community manager john
yountovic said on twitter that multiple
standalone playlists are coming to halo
infinite modes like fiesta tactical
slayer aka swat and free for all however
they won't be coming to the game on
december 8th when the campaign launches
the good news is that they should be
added by the holidays just in time to
challenge your grandmother on christmas
a social slayer playlist featuring
multiple variations of standard slayer
is also on the way and yuntsvik said
this has been among the most requested
additions to the game since it lost on
november 15th
the bad news is this won't be available
until after the holidays just in time to
challenge your grandfather on his
birthday
and in other online shooter news call of
duty warzone is getting its long-awaited
new pacific themed map this week leading
up to the new map's drop call of duty
warzone is hosting its last hours of
verdansk today kicking off at 10 am
pacific time 1 pm eastern this is a
limited time mode in warzone that
contains exclusive rewards for
participation and victory those who want
to play on verdansk one last time may
want to join this explosive finale where
bunkers are the only safe haven from
what will come the event will last until
9 p.m pacific 11 59 eastern after which
warzone servers will be offline until
the new map launches if you own vanguard
you'll get 24 hours of early access to
the map starting on wednesday december
8th at 9am pacific time other war zone
players will get access to the new map
the following day so if you made it this
far into the video hit the comment
section and just say happy birthday
philippe it's one of my friend's
birthdays and i want to wish him well
[Music]